i'm not nervous i'm just excited all
right
so my name is ryan tempe i'm a senior
data scientist at the lego group
on the marketing effectiveness team i
basically build marketing mix models in
r to help the lego group
optimize all their different forms of
media spending
you can find me on twitter at ryan tempe
where i like to tweet about my dog
dinosaurs and all the fun things i do in
r
you can also check out my twitter for
exclusive bonus content to this talk
that did not make the cut
so i'm here today to talk to you about
learning r by creating side projects
uh side projects have been a critical
part of my learning experience in r
and i want to share some of those
experiences with you today
whenever i'm interested in learning a
new package or a new technical concept
i actually come up with a project
designed for me to learn it
and then once i'm comfortable i can
begin using it in my work
so for example two years ago when tidy
text came out
i used data science to answer this
really important question
which season of the golden goal should i
watch when playing a drinking game
yeah this is silly and stupid but that's
my point
um so r is always changing and we're
always learning
and so sometimes it feels like a
struggle to keep up with all the new
technology and packages
and over my eight or so years of using
and learning r
i found that side projects really work
well for me
to learn these new tools on my own terms
and then
once i'm comfortable i can use them in
my work so i like to come up with this
really ridiculous question like the
golden girls drinking game
and this works for me because i get to
learn the new tool
uh using data and a topic that i'm
already familiar with
so the only unknown for me is the new
tool itself
so this is what i did with tidy text if
you're not familiar uh tidy text
is in package by julia silgi and david
robinson
that can take text and turn it into a
tidy data table
it's a really powerful tool that can
make possible data from anything
from literature to financial earnings
reports or in my case tv show scripts
and i just love the idea of these two
professional programmers out there
making this really powerful tool for the
r community and i'm just using it to get
drunk
um but you know what that worked so i
can make this look a lot more like data
science with some charts
uh so again
if you and your friends are hanging out
one night and playing the golden girls
drinking game
which season should you watch to
maximize your drink consumption
so if you're responsible and not
familiar with drinking games
you basically watch a television show
and each time one of the characters
performs a specific action you take a
sip of your drink
so for the golden girls when rose talks
about her hometown at st
olaf dorothy talks about her ex-husband
stan
or when any of the women eat cheesecake
you're gonna drink
uh in looking at this lovely beach
colored bar chart on the left
i proved with data science i remind you
that if you're going to play the golden
girls drinking game and you want to
drink the most to watch season five
and that's because in later episodes of
the season rose talks about her hometown
a lot
uh and you're gonna drink about 10 more
drinks that season than season six
that said uh i'm not sure how much of a
good idea it is to watch an entire
season of a tv show for one drinking
game
definitely not healthy so instead
look at the other chart on the right
this shows the cumulative drinks per
minute for each of the seasons
and here you can see that maybe seasons
four or six are going to be a better
idea for you because they ramp up the
drinks quickly in the first 100 minutes
um if you watch season five you need to
watch 400 minutes of the show or 16
episodes to exceed your drink
consumption from season four
or six um so this is how i learned tidy
text
i hope i hope you're proud of me um
and uh but i get it uh i
tidy text i use it all the time now uh
in all my projects both at work and for
side projects
and i get it like golden girls is a very
old show and you might not be interested
in that
so we can use tidy text for a lot of
other things
like the good place drinking game
because
once you learn how to do it once it's
really easy to repeat
uh so here you drink any every time
eleanor says fork
or janet reminds someone that she's not
a girl and here you're gonna watch
season one
or the jurassic park drinking game
literally any drinking game you give me
the
the tv show or the movie and i'll solve
it for you
um using teddy text and so um here
we now know that if you watch the two
hour movie you're gonna consume
80 drinks during the course of that
movie
and this one's a little bit different
because we're not optimizing a problem
there's only one movie or one movie that
matters
and uh but you know what i love the
movie
i already have the tools with tidy text
and i already have the data so i just
why not make this chart so
i already had the data because of a
different mini side project i did when a
different new package came out
so i want to learn how to make animated
gigi
gg plots with the gg animate package and
again using data that means something
for me is just
way more fun so i spent
three days watching jurassic park i
paused the movie every few seconds
uh to figure out which characters were
in the scene to count all the dinosaurs
on the screen
uh and to just jot down all the
locations uh
and i did this all for data science
so here we have animated character paths
of the main characters in jurassic park
and where they move throughout the movie
we have three maps we have the globe if
they move from the badlands where
they're digging up the bones
to the island itself we have a map of
the island in the middle
where they moved between the different
dinosaur exhibits and then we have a map
of the visitor center with the interior
scenes
and in the middle every time a dinosaur
eats one of the characters a little
skull emoji pops up
uh so this is a small silly project but
i learned gg animate this way
and now like i learned all the features
and transition elements and how to use
them and when to use them
and that set me up for me to use it in
some of my more serious work
sorry other times
i approach the learning experience from
the other side around
i dream up a really fun project i want
to complete with r but i don't have the
tools to do so yet
so take a look at this chart this is a
rolling average of some mortality data
from the united states it's generally
decreasing
so that's a really good thing uh take
another look though and look closely
do you think maybe does this chart look
like a dinosaur to you
and spoiler alert the answer is yes
um it looks just like a dinosaur
um so doodling on charts is a lot of fun
i do it a lot um especially with tablets
yeah um but for this project i wanted a
lot of doodles like thousands of them
um so in this case getting computer to
doodle for me was going to be way more
fun
so here we have another dinosaur doodle
drawn from this data
but this doodle was made with a lot of
data science and data science that can
create
any dinosaur from any data
yeah problems you never knew you had
um so a few years ago
it seemed like everyone out there was
building twitter bots
um and twitter bot is a win-win a
computer does all the work and a human
gets all the credit
all the twitter likes and all the
retweets and i wanted in on this
so i built data source
which takes a time series of data um
and it finds a dinosaur outline that's
closely correlated with it
it then redraws the dinosaur using that
time series as the outline
colors it in and displays it on this fun
poster
r sends out a tweet rinse and repeat
every few hours forever and you have a
twitter bot
the thing is when i set out to do this i
did not know how to do this
um my knowledge of r at the time was
very limited to data manipulation
and uh regressions and i didn't really
have the tools to accomplish my goals
here
uh so doing this i learned a lot of new
packages
um so i started with what i could do
uh and then i would plan out the next
step whenever there's a roadblock
i would do some research to see what
tools and packages were available for me
to accomplish this
and then yeah i would get it to work for
data source i learned the package along
the way
and i move on to the next one so some
examples of this
are i use the filopic api to actually
get all these dinosaur images onto my
computer
uh what's a geome raster actually lets
me draw the dinosaur on a gigi plot
grid extra to arrange a lot of gg plots
on the same chart
our vests because i wanted trivia facts
to make this more scientific
so on the bottom i had to scrape
wikipedia to display some facts
um you see the fun color patterns on
that i had to relearn some basic
trigonometry from high school because
that's all sines and cosines
our tweet and the twitter api to put
that into a pat or a tweet
and then batch processing so i did not
have to hit the enter button every time
i wanted to make one of these
so the output of this is really silly
but i learned a ton of new tools that i
use every day as
at my work as a data scientist not the
dinosaur drawing part but everything
else
and so solving this silly problem just
made me a much better data scientist
um before i move on take one more look
at that dinosaur
uh we use data science to make this
really cool dinosaur
right now to only exist on my computer
but pretend it's real for a second
do we have a brand new problem what do
we name it
um or if you're a paleontologist
and you are about to publish this brand
new dinosaur discovery
uh what are you gonna call it so from
what i can tell and i'm not a
paleontologist
um naming a dinosaur is a huge privilege
like there's these really great powerful
sounding ones that are used
like that use greek and latin like
brontosaurus which means thunder lizard
tyrannosaurus rex which means the tyrant
lizard king
and i want to name my dinosaur something
really cool too but i don't know greek
and i don't know latin so in this case
i'm going to introduce you to my friend
deep learning and artificial
intelligence quite possibly the
trendiest of the data sciences
so for this side project i use someone
else's side project
because i saw someone do a really cool
side project and i was like i could do
that too when i did it
so jaclyn nolis you may have seen here
give a talk a few hours ago
with heather nolis published a really
fun project
using recurrent neural networks to
generate new offensive license plates
from a list of plates that had been
banned in arizona
so people in arizona i guess sent out
like they tried to get some vanity
license plates with bad words on them
arizona said no way and then they kept a
list of those words
so she used that as her training set and
she generated this list
and a small sample was there um and
along with her output she shared her
code
in a blog post explaining some of the
math and tricks behind the algorithm
thanks to open source i clicked the
clone button on her repo
and i changed it to work for extinct
reptile nymphs
so after a few minutes my computer spat
out a list of brand new never before
seen awesome dinosaur names
so here we i can't say them all uh here
we have sterosaurus
metro terracops dinorirosaurus
allioraptor all these really awesome
sounding names that don't yet have an
actual animal attached to them
um but seriously i like this project
because it lowered the barriers of entry
for me to begin using deep learning with
keras and r
so ai and deep learning or buzzwords and
data science
closely associated with advanced image
recognition
and natural language processing and
that's true uh
but that association can make it super
daunting
uh for someone like me who is new to
deep learning to actually start
using a deep learning project so when i
saw something
using deep learning as simple with as
simple as license plates
i was really excited to leverage
jaclyn's work with my own data
so i could begin building my own models
and begin using deep learning and keras
in my work
and then finally uh side projects are
great because sometimes they can become
real things and land you a job
um so a while before i join my current
company
i want to figure out how to use the tidy
verse to
build a lego mosaic and to build it as
cheaply as possible
and so it's a relatively simple problem
you take an image you pixelate it you
change every pixel to a lego color
and effectively of bricks and then you
combine
single adjacent pixels or bricks of the
same color
and that saves you money and so i shared
this on twitter in a blog post
and people really liked it and that
motivated me to keep on working on it
and so i kept on developing this i added
a bunch of new features
some that were requested some that i
just wanted to do i
learned a lot of packages to make it
work and i
figured how to put it into a package of
its own and then
eventually i ended up with bricker
so bricker is an r package also a side
project
um that can take an image in a gg plot
and turn it into lego bricks
so you feed the function an image and it
returns a lego version of it
as well as the instructions you need to
build it and then all the pieces you
need to build it
it also can take a list of instructions
and then
create a 3d lego model for you
this in itself is a side project oh
thank you
i'll allow it
so this in itself was a side project
within a side project
because i really wanted to learn tyler
morgan wahl's raciator package
uh but again using data i want to use
not his data
so um instead of maps and topography and
boring stuff
i used it to make lego bricks
but in the process of doing this i
learned so much about his package how to
make it work
uh that in later versions i actually
switched from relying on his package
directly
and instead use his underlying source
code as a jumping off point to get my
project to work
uh but to be honest the cool factor is
pretty high with this
the usefulness factor is pretty low uh
no really low yeah um but developing
this has really helped me to
learn a ton of new things about r uh
there are so many tools needed to get
a package working uh and or at least
working well
and then to ensure that it builds
correctly for many people and is as
accessible as possible to as many people
as possible
uh in doing this and i'm still
definitely working on it this is not on
crayon because it's too much work
really challenges me as a programmer
and then beyond that building bricker as
a side project really helped with my
portfolio
so around the time i was working on this
the lego group decided to
hire data scientists in the u.s and just
let me tell you this
already having a portfolio of work
idolizing your future employer
can do wonders for your job application
yeah
and now i'm here standing in front of
you today at this super serious
conference
talking about drinking games um i'm
pretty sure i professionally peaked
so there we have it um working on these
humorous side projects really opened
some doors and developed me as an r
programmer side projects provide a safe
learning environment
to enable you to set yourself up so you
can succeed and learn on your own terms
uh and then building side projects can
create new resources for yourself and
others uh making it so much easier for
other people out there
to learn from the work that you did and
i hope maybe i've inspired some of you
to kind of go home with all these new
skills that you've learned over today
and you will learn tomorrow
and create some really cool side
projects and share them with me
so thank you i am happy to take any
questions and while we
wait oh thank you
why we wait we can check out the office
drinking game
all right
thanks okay so we have time for a few
questions i'm gonna see if i can
actually get this
out of here so i'm not tethered to it
okay uh so it looks like
one popular question is how do you find
time for side projects
yeah i was expecting that um
i mean i'm definitely privileged because
i have a lot of free time
i'm seeing all right i don't have any
kids right now so that's a big thing
um but i stopped playing video games at
one point and so i
found a lot of free time but that's it
okay uh another question we have from
the jacqueline nolis who inspired one of
your projects how did you make the
background maps
for the jurassic park gg animate
so i'm not a drawer but i uh got a
drawing
program on my ipad and traced it with an
svg
and then loaded the svg into the gg plot
which i originally had a slide on but i
had to cut it
easy question i like those
uh so maybe one final question and then
we might uh
get the next speaker set up uh have you
made charts of the variation
how much you have to drink per episode
um i mean the one we're showing on the
screen right here if it's still up
is it yes uh that's actually per episode
for the office i haven't done it for the
golden girls
uh but yeah in theory yes but i've never
played this game
any of these games just putting that out
there it's
purely for academic research
well i said that was the last question
but i have one more question that's
really good
and we have time you okay okay uh
so where do you get inspiration for new
side projects
i was a weird kid um these things come
to me and i just have to do it so like
i don't know yeah that's it's my brain
wiring
sorry so then my question is are you a
golden girls fan
oh for sure oh yeah yeah okay good so
what is your favorite character
depends on the episode and the yeah i
can't pick all four
okay mine's rose but i admire you for
picking yeah
you gotta go with one okay thank you
thank you ryan
you